the greatest threat that's coming
involves the purchasing panic that has
already begun it's just the beginning of
it and it's gonna continue over the next
number of days weeks and months in a way
that has never before been seen in the
history of mankind
you were you were about to witness the
wealthiest nation on earth buy
everything it's not funny what I've
witnessed in the last few days at Costco
in the grocery store as well as talking
to friends I have from across the
country what's happening now is about to
become a very big deal and it's gonna
become an even bigger deal within the
corona virus itself I would argue so and
regardless of whether you think all
these people they're stocking up on food
and toilet paper regardless of whether
you think that that's silly and that
these people are overreacting I'm here
to tell you right now that that no
longer that that's irrelevant
because so many people are now doing it
and those numbers are only going to
increase and there's no sign in sight of
it slowing down let me give you some
examples we all see on the news
before I'll say a hurricane is coming
and there'll be people in that region
flooding the grocery store lines really
deep people buying water and canned food
but that's like with a few days of
advance notice of hey the storms coming
it's gonna make landfall here and then
within a week things are back to normal
- the cleanup the thing is with this
coronavirus regardless of how bad or
deadly you think it is it's not gonna
slow down in that for the next number of
weeks or even within a few months this
will continue to spread and every day
that a new celebrity or public figure is
diagnosed with it more and more people
are gonna go to the store I was at
Costco on Thursday here in Boise Idaho
at 2 p.m. and look at these photos which
don't do it justice because they don't
show the lines that are wrapping around
I couldn't believe what I was seeing
there's so many carts that were full to
the brim of people loading up now let me
also quickly mentioned that the cashier
them himself said that this is as busy
or busier than the day before
Thanksgiving or Christmas which I
already knew because I saw with my own
eyes my other friend that lives in
Austin Texas was at a Costco that same
day that morning and the cashier said
the same exact thing another person in
California same exact thing at a car
go slammed like the day before
Thanksgiving this is happening
everywhere throughout the United States
I was also at my local grocery store
here in Boise yesterday Friday at 3:00
p.m. and Albertsons buy my house which
is a low-volume store this particular
one and I can't believe what I was
seeing people's carts were full to the
brim if you look at here of course the
toilet paper was gone I think everyone
has already seen or heard this the
toilet paper has been sold out
everywhere bleach almost all gone and
let me just quickly say that people
buying water that's a waste
don't buy water I'm gonna tell you later
in this video video exactly what to buy
but there's no reason to be stocking up
on water because there's no reason to
suggest or think that the city water
pumps are going to shut down or get
contaminated and even if they were you
can boil your water or if you get pure
non-scented bleach eight drops will
purify one gallon of drinking water do
not waste your energy buying water by
various canned foods rice and beans like
lentils which is a high percentage of
protein and the reason why I'm telling
you to stock up is because now that we
know that this is going to continue
regardless of how bad it actually gets
regardless of how small the percentage
of the population is that does get it or
doesn't get it or dies from it this
purchasing panic is going to accelerate
like I just mentioned and you have to be
prepared that if you have to self
quarantine because you should anticipate
getting it you're all Brawl getting it
guys vast majority of us will get it you
have to be able to know that you can
stay inside your home for a few weeks
also let me show you something or let me
say that other countries are doing these
vast lockdowns whether it's in Italy or
even look at France here's an article
and the US media isn't covering it but
this is today literally March 14th
Saturday mass protests of thousands of
people in Paris because they don't want
to be on lockdown I don't know all the
details but here's a short 20-second
video clip to paint you a picture here
we go
[Music]
so here's my point as this continues to
grow in the next coming weeks and maybe
month here in the United States it's
gonna start slow but then it's going to
skyrocket then you're gonna have various
leaders that are gonna have to make
decisions because they can't just sit
around and do nothing but their hands in
the pockets and look like fools while
this epidemic pandemics going on so
there may be lockdowns in major cities
whether it's LA Chicago Atlanta New York
whatever if that happens if you are
forced to be inside your home for weeks
on end and you have not stocked up on
food I wonder if that has anything to do
with the protests or if people just
think that it's being blown out of
proportion again the biggest concern now
is the supply chain so depending on how
bad it does get you may see and the
reason I'm sharing this is because if
these events if what I'm about to share
with you does happen you will have a
warning of just how significant this is
going to get but if you see various
domestic flights get shut down you may
see all domestic fights get shut down
because it may start with okay major
airports LA O'Hare Atlanta Chicago or
that is O'Hare New York Honolulu Seattle
stuff like that if that happens you may
have governors begin to shut down
borders and if they do that you will
witness a terrible fallout from the
supply chain that will already be
stressed because again as I show you the
pictures that you're seeing mark my
words come next week today's Saturday
the 14th come next week you will see in
the news holy crap this weekend
everybody was buying stuff because I
went by my same Albertsons again this
morning to buy bananas and it was at
9:30 in the morning when it's normally
slow there in the pace was packed
well almost packed the parking lot was
full and people were buying loads of
food so what I'm saying is that
regardless of how silly all that sounds
guys the events that are absolutely
coming which we know that the virus is
going to continue to spread because
guess what I don't care what you heard
on TV by someone saying that oh it
should probably go away when summer
comes around the warmer months when this
flu season typically ends one experts
have already debunked that and let me
tell you very logically that you could
think for yourself an example of how you
know that that's [ __ ] which is that
right now it is summer in the southern
hemisphere notice you don't hear anybody
anywhere talking about well hey wait a
second we know it's going to go away in
the summertime
just look at the southern hemisphere
there's no coronavirus there there is so
that's how you know that that's bullcrap
so for the coming weeks and months at
least a few months this will continue to
spread and again because I know a lot of
people are saying it's not as deadly as
a regular flu well hold on a second it
is about to be it's estimated it's gonna
be 10 to 15 fit 10 to 15 times worse
this year then all flu deaths expected
because the numbers are going to
skyrocket the mortality rate of the
corona virus is approximately 2 percent
the flu is just under 1% the corona
virus is more contagious so even though
it started small it's going to
eventually hit this curve where it's
going to skyrocket and I suspect that
that is going to be in the next few
weeks or inside or approximately a month
from now I don't know this I'm not a
freaking doctor ok what I do know is
that it's a numbers game and these
numbers are about to go up so regardless
of how bad you want to debate that it is
it's almost irrelevant because it's it's
all relative on based on the reaction of
it how many people are buying how much
stuff in depleting the stores and how
long you may have to wait inside if one
you have to self quarantine and 2 if
there's some sort of lockdown which may
happen and if that happens there are
going to be the haves and there gonna be
the have-nots picture hurricane katrina
for a second it's a different example it
was an isolated region while it was
large but different circumstances as we
know but within a few days of the
collapse of the system in the looting
and people not having stuff they need
there was some chaos now let me just say
I do not anticipate one that all these
borders gonna get shut down I do not
anticipate mass civil instability but
going back to that clip in Paris that I
just showed you it's fair to say that a
lot of Americans most Americans will not
prep for this that's what people do most
people don't prep it all and then all of
a sudden when they realize that there's
these quarantine and that things are
being put up the cities are being put on
lockdown and they haven't supplied
themselves many people will rebel
they'll write they'll go to try and
steal from others and again I'm not
suggesting this mean mass civil
instability but there is absolutely the
likelihood that in some areas for some
brief moments of time that you have the
losers the dumb violent people out there
that didn't prep at all
that will instead you're AB their weapon
and they will try and take from someone
else
that always happens that is what people
do even though a very small fraction of
the population would do that it's always
enough people to create some issues and
you don't want you don't want that to be
you so you also want to protect yourself
and you know what I mean by that
all right so let me also say I said I
would look at my notes okay here's what
you really freaking need to know about
this virus is that the numbers are
showing that a lot of people that are
dying aren't just elderly in the week
there are people in there this is data
from around the world now people in
their 40s are dying and they're smokers
or obese if you are a smoker because you
need to keep in mind that people are
suffering pneumonia and other
complications of the lungs because of
the chronal virus it's not the kernel
virus itself that's killing you it's
what comes after if you are a smoker or
a vapor whether it's tobacco or the good
420 you need to go cold turkey
right now you need healthy lungs and
within a short period of time days and
weeks your lungs will rebound incredibly
fast in your immune system will
skyrocket
so speaking of immune system you need to
start altering your diets to include
foods that are known to increase your
immune system not just vitamin C but
garlic avocado red peppers mushroom
onion dark green vegetables spinach or
broccoli and there's others Google this
and start implementing that to your
daily diet also if you're a big time
drinker if you drink on a regular basis
or if you like to go out and get
hammered on the weekends and do up the
bars you should stay away from that
because timing is everything and the
last thing you want is to get in contact
with the coronavirus which again you
should expect to get the numbers show
that most people will get it over time
and the last thing you want to do is
contact and get that crap after a long
weekend of drinking think about that so
cut that crap out of your diet now I
guess oh and then he also point out that
the doctor who exposed the corona virus
to the world and was silenced by the
Chinese government if you're not aware
he died because of the corona virus he
was 34 years old but he was a smoker
again what I witnessed at the grocery
store was I've never seen anything like
it when I witness at Costco and this is
just the first few days and just think
regardless again of how bad you think
this is or isn't gonna be what we do
know is that it's going to continue for
the foreseeable future at least for a
few months probably longer guys and so
every day more more people will like
alright I need to buy stuff the supply
chain is limited I'm not suggesting for
a second that people are gonna start
starving to death especially in the
United States but like your life could
be incredibly inconvenienced that you're
used to going to the store
fast food and you should anticipate the
things are going to start closing
schools so you can have a lot more
people that will be eating from home as
opposed to at school like they're used
to you may have movie theaters and
restaurants closed so like things were
gonna it's gonna stack on top of each
other the issues is what I'm trying to
say so if you're gonna suck up and rice
and beans do not forget to buy iodized
salt you need iodine in your body and as
a westerner American whatever our food
already has it you don't need it
Google what happens if you don't have
enough iodine in your system look at the
pictures you don't want that so if
you're relying on staple food like rice
and beans you need iodized salt buy a
couple of them another thing if you're
going to don't be a piece of [ __ ] human
and buy everything especially if you're
looking to sell it for profit like all
these [ __ ] that are buying toilet
paper and they're just selling it for a
massive profit don't be a piece of [ __ ]
human look out for your fellow man your
brother your neighbor don't like this is
like God people oh yeah so yeah don't oh
and don't forget pet food don't forget
pet food because again guys this might
all sound like panic this might sound
like okay he's being silly he's
overreacting no like again everyone else
is already doing it or not everyone
enough people and then it's gonna
increase with every day that new stories
and headlines come out so like it's not
gonna be undone and it's gonna continue
for the foreseeable future so the last
thing you want to be is one of the
have-nots just get ahead of it by an
appropriate amount I recommend a few
months worth honestly I bought a few
months with a dog food which wasn't
cheap because they're too 100 pound
German Shepherds but hey I'm looking out
for them I bought a few months worth of
various canned foods rice beans broth
boxes of Clif bars and other things like
that and I feel good i now have the
peace of mind that
hey if Jimmy gets coronavirus which I am
anticipating I'm not gonna stop going to
the gym or going out I'm gonna live my
life so I believe that I will survive it
I demand that I'm healthy enough and
I'll bounce back so I'll just quarantine
myself in my house I'm not going to the
hospital and that's another thing if you
start to feel a little sick look I may
be careful of what I say here but don't
just go to the frickin hospital because
there's only so many medical supplies
like if you are somebody that's at risk
then go but if you're just a healthy
person like guys they recommend just
drinking lots of fluid eat well and
vitamins and like that's all they can do
unless you're like you all you already
have other health issues so be careful
in that don't exhaust the medical supply
either don't exhaust the grocery store
don't exhaust everything or anything be
be good about it so anyways I'm gonna
wrap this up I said everything I think I
can say bless everybody again whether
you think this is a big panic an
overreaction or not it's already doesn't
matter because enough people are doing
it which means that now you have to
worry about it because panic or not you
only have so much food in your house and
if this accelerates which it will it's
gonna get worse before it gets better
then you have to worry about just
planning your meals out so think about
that anyways guys my name is Jimmy my
channel is called bright insight yeah
take care everybody I have work in
another video which I expect to have out
before the end of March hopefully it'll
be on the ancients should be an
interesting video so I'll leave it at
that I hope this information helps you
leave a comment share what your thoughts
are take care everybody